a little too bad how are you fantastic I
can't with its I mean we're gonna see
some awesome stuff with battlefield one
yeah in fact you know what Andrew let's
just let's just jump into it what are we
gonna see today well today we're gonna
take a look at Nivelle Knights
this is a first Knight map for about a
good one okay
Night Man yeah now what are some of the
challenges with Knight maps in
particular that you you found when you
were making the game like where you were
making you know these maps so obviously
the first thing that comes to mind is
lighting right you don't want to be in
complete darkness where you can't see
your opponent you want to be able to
view your opponent and get a good shot
off so it's really finding that fine
balance they're really getting in making
sure that you can be strategic so we
wanted to be able to make sure that you
could also find dark corners and hide a
little bit get where you needed to go
don't like my place I'll oh yeah
just hide in the corner the time in
order to snipe right that's good doing
no I just wait with a shovel you know
you're the shovel guy yeah back ahead oh
I roll what about you how do you play
well I try to stick to a saw I'm more of
an infantry player so that close-quarter
setting which you'll see in a minute
yeah is definitely something that you
could focus on on this new map having a
played it in the testing environment
you're gonna see some good close
quarters game yeah the trench the
trenches play really well here yeah they
do play really well and there's some
interesting differences between the two
trenches that I think we'll talk about
later on in the I can't wait I can't
wait to share it so many details put
into this now had a chance to play this
before yeah in the test server yeah um
was it as detailed as it is here or
people gonna see some new things that
they haven't seen before if they play it
in the server yeah so in it on our CTE
the community test environment it was in
it's kind of pre phase pre alpha phase
so you're gonna see a lot more details
so it's really refined making sure the
artwork is as polished as possible the
gameplay is as polished as possible so
you might find a few little areas for
cover that you probably didn't have on
the CTE okay I like that I like that a
lot it you know it's very exciting
because I think what a lot of people
thought about World War one and it's
exciting for some and for others it's
also concerning which you'll see in a
little bit they have nothing to be
concerned about because everyone thought
World War one trench warfare right now
must be so boring and obviously you guys
didn't do that when the game first came
out
but now you are bringing into the
trenches right what were some of the
challenges in making that combat feel
exciting well when you think of World
War one trench warfare it's one trench
on one side one trench on the other yeah
and you wait right who's going to storm
the other and then the guys who get up
out in into the open they're the ones
that die first
but this what the way we win about it is
we wanted to create a no-man's land in
between both trench sets so this created
we put a lot of cover and a lot of
interesting spaces where you can even
have some really good combat outside of
the trenches but once you go in the
turns and the corners and all the little
nooks and crannies tons of fun happening
all right well without further ado let's
go ahead and jump into it Neville Knight
here and this again you know this map
looks incredible if you guys haven't had
a chance to check it out here EA play
you oh man you're gonna you're gonna be
in for a treat here Wesley what do you
have anybody just wanted to say straight
up you might notice we're playing the
conquest game late but its own both sets
of teams have got two captured flags
already and then in the no-man's land in
the middle that's where you've got to
neutral uncontested flaps yeah that's
something really unique to this we
wanted to make sure that the two flags
were that were in your point are the
flags you already own we thought it'd be
really weird if you had to capture the
flags that were already in your trenches
okay is that something that you guys are
experimenting from this one or is it
something that we could potentially see
another master
yeah I think that Europe you might be
seeing some more of this future yeah cuz
if it's a little weird right to like
start the game off and you're like okay
well we know what we're gonna get right
so we might as well just get to the
action quicker right by just giving it
giving those those two spots there and
it also makes that encounter a bit more
intense for for CMD cuz you want to be
able to push out right in the middle
yeah
the no-man's land as you guys had
mentioned before okay so take a look oh
my goodness just got absolutely shredded
on that one Bonnie just did all the work
on that I think we're on board with
Stone Mountain here and we're in the
middle of no man's land heading towards
dead steel and you might just be able to
see over to the left as he goes over the
hill here you see the massive shell of a
shot to see that he lived there that's
been added in recently I think yeah so
what you're seeing now is the remains of
the shelling right what happened in this
time this is this is based on Nivelle
offensive where you had a shelling
attack on the German front and and this
is what we're seeing this is the results
you're fighting with in the midst of
that they're doing their absolute best
to be able to maintain control here of
see you get dead steel lock down wonder
what stones gonna wear he's gonna send
us shoots all there they're looking to
push forward you're looking to push
toward V take B okay I like that stone
now in unit 64 on the move when he's
gonna find someone in front of him nice
kill there on qjb take a seat Bob and
man it's interesting that he's decided
to go for the B point rather than going
for the other no man's land flag so what
he's essentially saying to his troops is
look let's take their trench line and
force the issue onto them because as we
said they were already captured for that
team anyway and they've decided to just
go straight for it and take those flags
and study
this is exciting because you know the
players right now you have to make a
decision I mean if I'm you know find
this squad I'm I'm thinking okay well if
we need to push we have to get a little
aggressive we have to you know do our
absolute best here to kind of maintain
our positions and you know the German
forces they only have two flags at this
moment meanwhile on the other side
though the French they're dominating
they are dominating at the moment and
actually as we were watching Stone
Mountain they're going for some of the
the enemy trench lines we ended up
seeing that the two objectives that they
to run away from and they don't get
taken by the enemy team so that the
whole map sort of flipped itself on its
head for a bit here's this on your
screen here sorry miss Ella Cronin
missile although the title crying in the
tank
wait who's ever tank out right now look
in front of them you see the ahead that
you also got a little activity in the
trenches down there as well that player
knew that he was in a real bad spot so
you had to get out of Dodge as soon as
he possibly could then one of the things
I do like about this with the trenches
is you know there is that it's all right
there
miss just through the the nade over who
knows who they'll hit right like you'll
never know it right into trenches yep
anybody feel hiding behind those corners
oh boy marks ended up getting kicked off
there the Lighting's really interesting
in the trenches here actually because
you've got some points that are very
well lit it's just certain parts and if
you go into the straight narrow trench
moving towards the next alight if you've
got almost nothing in between so you're
just seeing the outlines of players off
in the distance yeah what in what's left
of the
like those those spaces well let's talk
about the lighting rooms because there
is a distinct difference between the
French and German side right when it
comes to the lighting yeah so this is
really an interesting part of the map we
took a lot of interest in creating a
differences between the sides and with
the way we did that what you'll see is
there's quite symmetry in this map the
way we did that to change it up is how
the lighting played a big role so we
made one side the German side you'll see
a lot of electric lights
so you'll see service lights you'll see
a lot of light bulbs and that's going to
be a good indicator that you're on the
German side of the map so that's is
actually quite true to history to what
we saw was the Germans buckled down they
fortified their trenches and that's why
they survive this attack and then the
French side is going to be a lot more
organic you got fires
you got flames keeping it keeping it lit
and everything's kind of wood and it's
all it's all very organic on that side
almost feels like it's a little bit
though it's been mated a hundred like it
was like I've got to make this now
before the Germans like that book the
French and we didn't have a lot of time
don't care well what we saw too is that
the French kind of thought that the the
Nivelle offensive was going to be a big
a big win they were they did the
shellings and they thought this is going
to be it so they weren't in it for the
long haul
but they proved to be wrong yeah one of
the things I really enjoyed about VF 1
when it came out and we're still seeing
it today it's weak I feel like we have a
new generation of history buffs who have
emerged because of Battlefield one like
people who are genuinely into the
history of
yeah because it is it's a great war but
there is so there's so many stories to
tell and things that people just don't
really know about which is makes it very
you know guessing encapsulating right it
makes you want to learn more but you
know we're gonna check out the sniper
game personally man doom 49 don't let us
down buddy get those shots all's yeah he
was able to get an enemy hit they're
giving him 80 points he's just gonna
continue to march down here 240 getting
rid up for the Danzig train branch I'm
looking for him to take off some phases
here it'll be pretty tough if he's able
to do so and they have four points right
now so they are marching down the
battlefield no pun intended
I'm sorry it's actually very interesting
because if you little bit looking oh
that was a nice shot there that was
lovely
but if you look at the points as I oh
it's good on the street oh no if you
would have gotten that shot through the
trees I would have just put this heads
down way but yeah if you look at even
though the teams are slightly imbalanced
on their flags at the moment the actual
score between the two is very very close
yeah and [ __ ] maybe it's just the fact
that when this was all organized I went
we're gonna make this really evil but
yeah I know right hold a bayonet charge
there
Oh didn't pay off for him I think he
missed his target gamers snack with the
pickoff there Paul what are your
thoughts yeah and Weston sorry Andrew
the horrors Westy I I think to your
point I think that because this is a
balanced map it's a very symmetrical I
think that this is that's what makes
this really easy
yes I mean looking at it but the
structure of it almost with the trench
lines being very similar yeah you've
almost got that that feeling constantly
anyway you've got that branch quick I'm
out of here
that's you've got that feeling of it
being very balanced from the start and
it's just depending on whether your team
communicate properly whether uses one
leader function to make sure that you're
covering your own objectives and then
attacking like another single or maybe
two objectives at once and then that
balance can remain but if you decide to
go too far forward and push too much and
don't cover the flags that you currently
own
then the enemy tinkerer getting those
trenches is very hard to get them out
yeah absolutely
I'm looking a hole down here on the in
the front line it's a
report of such so you got four to five
buildings around you and good cover as
well and and high ground advantage as
you can see x-factor taking advantage of
those opportunities when he seeds bit
this guy man he is a fantastic
battlefield player and also great
youtuber as are all of these creators
here great streamers while it happened
to tune into his twitch streams quite a
bit but mugs bugs manages to find him
but luckily for him pony lion was there
on the pickup not just a pilot he's a
great man ahead as well that's what
you're looking for an emetic yeah you
need somebody to come and revive your
players that's the thing man good town
playing a squad and my team they always
a man then again I do tend to like run
out all the way out and play row the
field yeah you know just like follow me
you know get the hint dog like just come
with me and we'll win the whole game
you'll that lone wolf gonna botch oh
yeah I'm the worst kind I what I do
typically those I happen to attain and
then I just drive around as much as I
possibly can and destroy people speaking
of that how many tanks can you get on
nipple night so there's one tank on each
side okay that's the plan here we wanted
to keep it pretty infantry focused so
once you start going too heavy I mean
you're gonna get some cavalry as well
okay so that's where that's where you're
gonna get a little bit quick gameplay
but we wanted to de say
very infantry focused I think that's
really good because obviously you've got
these trench lights and that's for a
reason right you want the trench lines
to be utilized yeah so if you gave them
loads of vehicle suddenly everyone's not
using the trenches that you built right
and especially because you built a lot
of the objectives around the trench
lines the only the other two are the
ones in no-man's land in the middle yeah
and then and that's why there's no no
planes in here as well
right we don't want you having fun
yeah arches that it really takes away
from it that's no fun yeah you're in a
trench like what more can you yeah yeah
I can hold out we all know how that goes
oh boy here we go dogs looking too good
jeez look at the destroy support don't
we make fantastic sniper man I want my
gun use a lot and he'll have two great
sniper oh don't pay to go with the
secondary and nice lickle the tightest
that is we said he was sorry Anna you
give up all the compliments they never
pull through it always happens that way
always revive there it is I love it
there you go
March on down x-factor you're done this
is one of the the new weapons that's
just been introduced as well that you
guys introduced it was it the is it the
may or the spring update I think you
added a few new variants yeah we had
some variants that we introduced in the
May update
yeah so this is the how spring update it
is me I think isn't spring update this
is the hell regaled offensive which is
yet an optical sight 120 round drum
magazine why Keaveney thank many bullet
well you know if you really want to
spring praise that's you and it's also
got the bipod as well so I guess if you
wanted to set it up behind cover and
literally as as the when you label on
you are gonna be hearing a little more
accurate let's see see if we can look at
this spread on the bullet to you see the
way that they're just really going like
it's my order yeah which is fantastic
like that's circle Oldham do you want to
see here that the good I paid off you
took all heltah yeah nice he's gonna try
and charge in here oh there it is this
is how it works there we go the one and
only a dankness four to nine he hates
that name but I'm gonna keep saying it
every time you'll pop some smoke get
some cover yeah it's interesting again
here because we're all bored with the
who are we onboarding they were all
bored with the French army and they're
taking back the flags that they had at
the start of the round right and as you
can see at the top there from the the
flag layout they are sort of fairly
behind in terms of the flights that got
other by bit well that's all there are
you but they're ahead on score so the
Germans need to pick up a little bit
looking around here darkness issuing
goes disagreeing to us borders but
[ __ ] can be blessed one yeah there we
go
there it is so they're now going to
capture that second objective [ __ ] a
minute right trash line all lovely toys
out there background
darkus man telling you team's name isn't
think so there's there's miss Ella
Cronin way mistakenly called missile a
little while ago but she's flying
through the trenches like a missile oh
there you go but I gotta you gotta bring
it back so now it's that worried that
works one in front
Wow I wasn't looking for that new can do
command where's your awareness off
humble the dude 849 one and only I think
he's top bragging on his squad there
we're honest hold on the whole team as a
matter of fact look at that yet again on
the on the topic of lighting andreas
arts your question because battlefield
one has sort of dynamic weather in it
that's right does the evil Knights have
the same kind of dynamic weather the
other cops do no we're not gonna see any
storms or any sand or anything like that
better this takes place on the on the in
French soil or on French soil so so it's
gonna be kind of what you see here we
feel like the night is really kind of
what's we're we're we're we're we want
to create that atmosphere yeah yeah I
mean the the darkness itself gives a lot
of coverage and imagine adding anything
more into that it could be a little bit
difficult the we on board with here
think it's doom 49 but they're all we
takes the shot so darkness
oh there you I had to like he said
garden and dark and showed up like dude
it worked right it it's late good played
real well well I do want to mention that
we haven't seen it yet and I hope I hope
one of our game changers managed to make
it happen but what about the elite
man jealousy's a plan for action I do
too
roasting some fools in the trench I do
too this is also a great opportunity for
maybe a trench Raider we have the trench
right oh this one I think we might be
seeing that it would be only fitting to
have a trench Raider with a trench map
that's a very good point but he's fine
with it
note that red shipping with the French
pact I mean this is an extension of this
pass this map here so we really I think
we should we should see if they can pick
one up by the way can be coming on how
close this game is right now for 34 42
for 31 but it seems like the German
Empire they're starting to rally the
troops and capture all the bases all
their base belong to the Germans Empire
and they are dominating right now this
seems pretty true to history I think me
not even at the truth the Frenchy to
find a way to fight this one back the
elevator comes they are taking a couple
of the flags actually you can see a lot
of them are actually up for content
you've got a de and F well now de in F
their contention yep but as you can see
they're all being taken by the enemy
team as we're watching so it may come
down to a point where we're looking at a
lot of flags being taken by one team and
not being held by the others we're seing
a lot combat here in the no man's own
right yeah and we just need to see
people running towards the flag is
trying to capture the points because as
much as the trenches can be very lethal
when you run around the corner or maybe
get hit with a shotgun you know they do
provide a lot of cover at the same time
if you know no one's in that trench you
can take cover in it yeah it's a great
place to chuck a grenade as we saw
earlier yeah but it is hard though right
to determine that so many turn so many
corners you just never quite know what
you're gonna find and by the way miss
Ella is just rushing it up well there
you go again you just did it just you
know Andrew gave the curse I'm sorry
mrs.
over two marks now once again sniping
from know they closed shoe this that
he's using the labelled sniper which is
the fracture see fine so sorry missed it
some of those flick shots but I mean how
do you do that yeah I'm just like I sit
in or watch people who could sniper
video and just incredibly no they are
like two of my favorite snipers to watch
on Twitch whenever they're streaming
because they are so unbelievably cool to
do this gun but oh no mugs taking a lot
of shots to the left though he's gonna
have to dive right into the trench get
you know yeah let me get himself drank a
Carter well I can see the players up on
the hill over the far side that's who
he's looking for he's gonna meet Brett
effect yeah we got oh there we go like
two nights I can see that kind of guy
she's taking a hitch on it oh all it
takes a just literally oh yes do is
breathe on him and bugs will fall here
so hahaha he's got to be very careful
there is a pathogen good night good shot
there muds looking to do it again there
you go there you go you even need a gun
all you had to do is take a bullet and
then throw it at mugs and then bugs
would have would have died this on that
alone now doom looking it was a best
mugs impression here look at that school
now the friendship pulled it all the way
back round I can't believe it
this is finally filled out it's fine
it's actually a really good game oh it's
so close very impressive stuff here
we're storming dead still here the Alex
like we're heading that direction
hey it's one of thanks this is x-factor
of a1 and Olay tur just annihilating
this is what I love to do personally you
just see this hang can go over and Julia
weed out all those little yeah you know
cretins there in the trenches oh yeah
okay you want to be careful how to fall
into the trenches he probably would have
fallen at this month right
it's the splash damage potential he's
got here just firing it against the wall
waiting for the infantry okay Hannah oh
oh he's it oh he's in so still managed
to move around Kenya but I think there's
going to be some really tight spots but
we also have cavalry in there yeah cuz
we ever once is that it's possibly cold
kitchen sink
is it possible to get out of the trench
Network what Idol I'm thinking no oh wow
wait oh my god created let's see what we
could it is gonna work oh oh he's not
wow I mean for us going through the
trench right you're going although
limpets come into the tank coming I was
like you to me I believe he like ran
away he saw that no that's the CC 2040
so the tank it was like oh boy oh boy
that was not going well we didn't ways
you begun for the libtech hill yeah oh
those guys they would go for the live
the kill oh my goodness gonna sit for
the repair right here so there's oh oh
they're storming they're starving oh now
what are you
he I think he's stuck
I look at these absolutely legit Noel
he knows he's stuck too and rule number
one is never leave your vehicle yeah so
we might see a really boring game to me
i disagree I think this is awesome
Kenny kills they got always knows what
they're all trying to think about here
we go a long we've got this all wet we
popped up a little bit what he's trying
to do is get to one of the ridge to the
light level there we go you yah - yes
there we go climb up I'm up somebody
need to know - get behind the tiger
Charlie good oh well I guess absolutely
not gonna happen
if he can get to one of the rear
trenches it doesn't open out go get
round yeah there might be a way here oh
yeah
and we're gonna see it yeah
[Applause]
victory nod right here so happy back of
a man's land where it feels comfortable
yeah I malleable room gets out at that
moment and then just gets bombarded oh
that would have been amazing
I was very battle it was very loyal to
see because if he left the tank not only
could the any of enemies he would have
got in it but if it had elected another
tank II wouldn't have spawned yes so
he's kind of left the shell yeah about
mana celui hello he took it into the
trench himself he was very good for
getting it you know I like that you're
finding the positive there that's not
fullfil st that's all right find the
positives and the negatives but just
update everyone on the score i mean this
is a really cool game really super 658
645 the action continues to rage on here
tickets are still coming yeah we have 9
minutes and 45 seconds left in the in
this game and we hope you guys are
enjoying it once again if you're just
joining us here you're checking out
Neville Knights in a new map that is
going to be coming to battlefield 1 it
is the first night map that this game
has and it is awesome yeah and it's
coming later this month later this month
I'm so excited and also the the other
map as well you did to her I can't pay
that much that one I've had to practice
for yeah I hope I'm saying you're right
[ __ ] you guys just call it like you
know like darkness well that would have
worked right it would have been fitting
oh man
speaking of darkness we're going over
the team darkness here with love tv5 fun
in front of them that dr. pill pill up
that's never mind skilled down for you
sir oh very good that was a nice one
that's what I do you know why they pay
me moderate how many dollars they keep
coming
oh they got the hit he's going for that
upper torso shot dick polite land it he
was on for a head shot that's what you
were hoping for the duck or something
mugs only goes for the face it's just
how he operates would you say it would
be only for the mug only for the mug oh
you're like a sir you should become a
commentator a new man reached I cannot
be as good as you guys through this more
often
I love it alright waiting around here
mullet we're playing in no man's lap
yeah a lot of the gameplay that we've
seen has been if it's no man's land
erection but we haven't seen some really
good trencher dinner
I think it's typical of the conquest
game over in the constant movement there
blow yeah so if you if you leave your
own church you go into no-man's land
taken objective the chances are the
enemy team Swain trail behind you taking
one of the observers oh and I found my
biggest success is usually when I'm
trying to oh one or two points I can't
even with you right now mugs I know you
guys are trying to like talk about how
great I was having trying to be
strategic about this this is how you do
it this is like having ribbons left and
right you just go through any shred
period man let's take D I hope he can
take this you just renamed himself a
blender white Oh lad that shot he was
going to show and suppressed by that
wire he landed it straight in the chest
sky man he is just absolutely incredible
they can cover in the chapel here the
ruins looking for the next whoa headshot
oh is that a head shot I don't know here
we go fell it was close you want dead
mojo good good
I can't believe the shops he's getting
he's just getting assists that they're
counting his kills cuz they're like why
of course why not
well he's John is finishing it off
go I think there was one more left it
made out always switch kits switched out
to the support kit he was probably
running out of ammo bare-legged good
players I just know that I haven't I
haven't run out of ammo before yeah what
that's like uh happens me long time old
there's a trick oh there it is there it
is
that was a trend trader kill I wonder if
he was doing I couldn't see the map of
who was actually running the church
trader here we got stone man following
horse this is great unit 64 himself
unfortunately we're not in a trench but
we are taking cover here this is gonna
be a good one I'm going out of the
pillars of the ruins so this wood I
haven't had a chance to tinker around
with the trench Raider yeah yeah so fun
is he super quick all melee so you're
not running you have a little extra help
because you have this armor on it
yeah it is just all-out war this guy
runs around Oh makes him deadly straight
ready one hit kills get ready you can
remember it if you can land it go
I'm hoping this is something leave
yourself stone no don't get shot leave
him alive oh there's one Jehovah sorry
buddy could have over gotcha you can see
sharp remember Lee Oh more like a land
fish oh man oh one hell space oh he's
out east oh my goodness hey beautiful
that was good so well that was good
advice fellows fun he knew the pressure
was on him he heard us in the venues a
huge well I got show up right now but
screens on me absolutely three kills in
a row that was worth it yeah definitely
the orange Raiders like one of those
counter-attacks though because it's like
you got to take only go your melee
weapon it's like you do have the
revolver but it's not it's not the same
as an automatic
and the club side one-hit-kill but you
really want to use that guy yeah
definitely and it's like if you know
there's a couple of players around the
corner
you're good enough else back for a
minute today you help that isn't it just
old Stormin yeah yes you get a win by
the way guys an update five minutes left
in the game vomited 17 seconds week Zach
and it is still a close affair between
these two teams
8:28 to 839 and the points just keep on
ticking we're on board right now with
darkness 4 to 9 an incredible twitch
streamer by the way via get ever get a
chance to check him out all these guys
once again I said it before I'll say it
again amazing creators that we have here
at EA play looking to just have some fun
and also show off some great gameplay on
the new map Neville Knight coming very
soon mix month no coming this this month
oh this one very soon you know what we
haven't seen yet what we have to see yet
no one has actually called in for an
artillery strike you can clear is an
artillery to do that how do you know
that
wait you don't get a tell us tell you I
think we should see if anyone can figure
it out yeah I can't go into it yeah if
it doesn't happen by the end of the game
we should jog yeah those are the games
start off with a artillery strike though
in the middle of the map so you do have
a little bit of that kind of set the
moat the mood keep you doing your point
yeah I like that I like that quite a bit
of prevents everyone from like going
nuts and just charging traits in the
middle like a bunch of crazy people and
it also adds like a little bit of like
story of the army I mean that's the job
done and that's
but will the vu almost into my score at
the moments are you real but but there's
no tickets in it is literally a tie
school eight so far so close yeah but if
you're not being ties for soon we are
going to the time to see you guys know
so so three minutes 50 seconds 50
seconds okay and this this game could
not be any closer if we tried I swear we
did not rehearse this this happened last
year at games go as well both games went
down slow quiet it did that's right
happens every time we do this and so
happens when you get a bunch of good
players in one room and just have them
Duke it out man 100% June here with
trusty shotgun oh oh yeah that's got to
hurt yeah you have to scream you knew it
was coming okay it's on its way
yeah well that's funny cuz he's like
looking around he's like he's gonna buff
me or is it go guy and then there's no
tray in front of you going through your
kidney here well I guess that's a good
point of the vertical gameplay that
you're gonna get here oh he wasn't even
on go where man and he was a target as
soon as our shooting you just especially
with the dark Mac random
it's laid out the muzzle fire you really
see then you can tell and again that's
where the lighting really plays a role
in this game what you're able to do yeah
really find such nice dark corners but
what you're also going to see when they
start sniping is puzzling the hilltops
those silhouettes that are moving you
see the movement by the way and that's
correct because over the back you have
some much like some a little of it so
here yeah interesting
2 minutes 25 seconds but 9:24 renamed MP
warrior
yeah the gaps opened up just a tad Oh
rocket go cup all diplomatic damage that
was a deflect Zakaria engine disabled
could he finish it off and we don't know
it's gone beautiful just go for it stone
just shoot and believe in yourself man
shoot into the darkness at the rachels
glowing time to charge all right well
they are gonna be able to overtake seat
both teams have three flags but the
scene deep like our swap so spike to see
a lot of activity who's going to be able
to win out that battle in the midfield
is the question Stone Mountain rallying
with his team forward shooting his
teammate because reasons and it's over
to a and they're going all the way out
to the other side of the map for that
last-ditch effort here Andrew son Isaac
is I hope we see some something
incredible here but they have to cap at
least two in order for them to come back
into this one idea one minute and 23
seconds because it's not sure it's what
happened yeah no I won't have we're down
they are capturing two points I can't
see it happening personally I think it's
gonna go
I think three ticket nah they're not
gonna do this not gonna do it
not gonna happen gonna be real tight
let's see see if it happens to
resupplying like go to a thousand and
that's right as a matter of fact it was
2000 but I don't think you know I mean
we figured we were gonna make it there
or till the game ending either way
though they needed to stop literally
everything from happening and that was
not the case
team darkness will reign supreme oh boy
what a what a match yeah well it's kind
of fitting too because it was a dark
matter
I have to say well you know let's go
ahead and take a look at some of the
highlights from that game because it
were a metric crap-ton from that game
and I have to say doom 49 had a couple
great shots as well as mugs mugs I think
was a superstar of this whole game
though she's getting shot after shot
after shot
he was absolutely tearing it up I mean
like if watching mugs do some of that I
think it's just it's not it's sometimes
so even the accuracy it continued
accuracy beyond the first shot like
first or second or third every single
shot lapse
yeah credible only about a foot moments
right there yeah and here's the thing
that's not just marketing to me that is
like actual yeah like you know you get
these crazy moments in this game because
of the open nature of it right that's
what you lent it to the super dynamic
yeah this is the stuff that drives us
when we're making you games you want to
make sure we provide these ways to
create those moments and I'm
particularly glad because as a person
who really enjoys infantry combat combat
I like that this mount agree
highlights the infantry combat it's a
lot of fun yeah right you know the gun
mechanics in battlefield are fantastic I
want to be able to take advantage of it
as much as possible and you know do my
thing here yeah you know so awesome
stuff all around you have to say and
yeah I mean what's he thoughts on the
map
I think the maps are really really good
because it's the first light map very
different from anything that you've
created so far the lighting really lends
itself to a different style of game you
can see that the trench close-quarters
action yes you can't get us someone on
some other maps but because of the
nighttime setting everything's a little
bit closer together so it's much more
chaotic yeah we saw a lot of close
quarter combat here yeah I loved it it
was awesome
I liked the clothes for combat once
again but I think that's something that
we're all gonna kind of echo here
because it's very yes you have it in
other maps but it's just a different
feeling it's a different tone I really
feel like you know if I had to think
about how bf1 would do
full-on trench combat that is admittedly
how I would want it to be so glad to
hear that yeah I'm glad I'm glad that it
was able you know it was nailed right
cuz when I lay this I'm gonna be super
into it because I just can two trenches
hide a corner shotgun some fool hit it
with a pan it's awesome stuff oh you
guys like pans ah that might come up
now that you've recommended I'm Larry
got on the list oh yeah if the designers
Revelation is here dude I'm telling you
man I I'm a great game designer kind of
sort of not really alright guys well
awesome time here but for nava let's go
ahead and send it over to Jose who's
down on the floor Jose what you got for
me buddy